assaut meurtrier aux abords du capitole
le siège du congrès américain a été visé
par une attaque ce vendredi un membre
des forces de l'ordre a été tué et un
autre blessé par un suspect en voiture
une attaque qui intervient moins de
trois mois après l'invasion du bâtiment
par des partisans de donald trump
le suspect a percuté deux de nos
officiers avec sa voiture puis a heurté
la barrière d'orientation nord le
suspect est sorti du véhicule avec un
couteau à la main
nos officiers sont alors intervenus le
suspect n'a pas répondu aux ordres
verbaux
c'est une période extrêmement difficile
pour la police du capitole après les
événements du 6 janvier et maintenant
l'événement qui s'est produit ici
aujourd'hui
cette attaque au capitole déjà
fragilisée depuis les événements du 6
janvier a fait réagir la sphère
politique américaine le président joe
biden s'est dit dévasté
d'autres personnalités de premier plan
ont également fait part de leur émotion
nous nous tenons aux côtés des hommes et
des femmes courageux de la police du
capitole aujourd'hui et nous les
remercions de continuer à assurer notre
sécurité
prière à l'officier william evans qui a
fait le sacrifice ultime et aux familles
touchées par cette tragédie un sens et
dans un acte de violence inexplicable
un courageux agents de la police du
capitole américain william evans a été
tué dans l'exercice de ses fonctions
alors qu'un autre agent se battait pour
sa vie l'agent evans a fait le sacrifice
ultime pour protéger le capitole nous
sommes de tout coeur avec sa famille et
ses proches
les médias américains accusent noah
green un jeune homme noir de 25 ans
d'avoir perpétré cette attaque
sur les réseaux sociaux il y aurait
exprimé sa sympathie pour le dirigeant
du mouvement national islam connu
notamment pour ses propos antisémites
d'après les forces de l'ordre cet assaut
dirigée contre le capitole ne serait pas
lié au terrorisme